one of the big things that happened
during our vacation
is that the trump organization meaning
trump's business
uh and its cfo alan weisselberg were
indicted on multiple criminal charges
15 felony counts against alan
weisselberg now this is significant
the charges are serious they involve a
tax fraud of various kinds
including failing to report and pay
taxes on a bunch of different benefits
cars
apartments school tuition it includes
state and federal income tax fraud
state and local tax fraud more generally
the reaction from the right and from
trump's family
exactly as everybody who's been paying
attention predicted has been
this is bogus politically motivated
nonsense
but of course because they can't seem to
resist trump's children don jr and eric
trump went on tv
and basically admitted they did all the
stuff they admit to it in the context of
saying this is small potatoes
they admit to it in the context of
saying we're only being targeted for
this for political reasons but
they admit to it much like trump did at
his rally in florida over the weekend
they both
don junior and eric had complete
meltdowns in this first clip
we're going to look at newsmax host eric
balling
asking eric whether he thinks hiro's
siblings might be indicted
and eric just loses his mind and starts
talking about
hunter biden if you can believe it let's
take a look at this here eric
are you concerned that they may send
into indictment your way your brother's
way or your sister's way
you know what i'm not eric because guess
what you know we've always lived
amazingly clean lives and believe me if
they could have they already would have
right there is no way
that this was going on 15 years at the
trump organization
and none of the trumps knew nothing
happens at the trump organization
without trump
or one of his kids knowing it it's just
not plausible
i mean that's what they wanted that was
their end goal you know the difference
is i'm not hunter biden
i'm not selling paintings to undisclosed
people for half a million dollars a
piece i'm not doing
you know drugs there's no reason to
believe there's anything criminal
in what hunter biden is doing with his
paintings in in shady hotels i'm not
i'm not going out soliciting
prostitution and i'm not going out and
you know selling influence to ukraine
and china and having lavish trips paid
for a while
you know my fault those things can all
be investigated but it's not
the subject of this interview father's
commander-in-chief no i'm not doing that
you know what we do
don ivanka and i live really you know
nice clean lives and we work very very
hard and guess what
long before politics ever came into you
know our lives
we were in the business world and we
were successful and we worked very hard
and we lived clean lives it was very
different than the bidens
who were never in business until their
father actually got into politics and
and they've milked it for everything
it's worth and they still do it to this
day and
you know eric where is the d.a there you
know when you have text messages of of a
prostitute so much of what he's talking
you know the
the d.a a lot of that stuff is in
different jurisdictions there are
allegations many of which have been
looked into and found to be completely
baseless
just melting down completely now in this
next clip from fox news
eric trump admits these are employment
perks
everything that's alleged is true but it
simply shouldn't be a criminal matter
he's saying
you know eric you don't have to do these
interviews i don't think he knows that
yeah well these are employment perks
these are
you know these are um you know a
corporate car which everybody has i
guarantee you there's people
who doesn't have a corporate car guys
come on this network that has corporate
cars i guarantee you there's people in
every
company in the country that have
corporate vehicles this is what they're
going after this isn't a criminal matter
this is
you know it's really interesting raymond
after the financial crisis
right they didn't so you see what he did
there he admitted admitted to all of it
but he says this just
isn't a criminal matter or what he means
is it shouldn't be that's his opinion
but he's admitting to the stuff that's
what's amazing after a single person on
wall street despite the fact that these
people were
literally they took down the us economy
but they'll go down they'll go after
somebody after
fringe employment benefits is that
really what the dea is focused on as
little girls are getting shot in the
middle of times square they'll go after
a corporate vehicle and a corporate
apartment give me
understand that there's not a single
denial here he's admitting all of it
he's just saying they shouldn't be
focused on this
break and honestly i have to say the
media has actually been very fair about
this
the new york times um you know so many
of the different news outlets
they've literally said this isn't this
isn't criminal this isn't
worth 40 50 investigators and it did
this would normally be this would
normally be a civil
complaint uh okay so there there is that
and then don jr um on fox news with
uh dan bongino also admitting all of it
but just saying this shouldn't be the
focus of the criminal system
yeah they they dressed up the indictment
obviously they dress it up they make it
look really serious
they say he didn't pay taxes on 1.7
million dollars worth of stuff over 16
years
so that's to new york state 8 percent of
that 136 000
half of that was because my father paid
for his grandchildren's
school in new york city did you so
that's one of the allegations
that donald trump just directly paid
alan weisselberg's grandkids tuition
uh that has to be taxed if i have a
business lease the amount that my
business pays for my car lease
i'm i have to pay taxes on that that is
a benefit and
that's a lot less money than what we're
talking about here for tuition don
is basically saying it was over a long
period of time
and it's not that much money per month
but he's admitting it all
so you take that out it amounts to about
five grand a month oh that's what they
promised they
brought in outside prosecutors they
teamed up with the attorney general of
new york state to do this so while
so there it is not denying any of it
their their strategy is
admit it all in plain sight but say it
shouldn't be criminal
and there's prosecutorial discretion
that's being applied in a politically
biased way
do they know they don't have to do these
interviews and that they don't have to
say these things or is this genuinely
the only way
they can think of to defend themselves
to say yeah i mean we kind of did it all
but none of it should be illegal or at
least it should be a civil issue
or at least they should go after
somebody else disastrous and
they've essentially over the weekend don
jr eric and donald trump himself at his
rally in sarasota
they admitted to all of it but they're
saying it just really isn't that serious
unbelievable and we'll see if that
defense works out for them it actually
may
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this one of our sponsors
is curiositystream the subscription
streaming service that offers
thousands of documentaries from the
world's best filmmakers
so yes there are some documentaries on
netflix
hulu amazon but none of those streaming
services give you
anything close to the selection of what
you get
on curiositystream they have all the
newest and most critically acclaimed
documentary titles
i'm always finding amazing stuff that i
can't find
anywhere else i just actually watched
engineering the future and just super
interesting about
we really may be on the precipice here
of a total paradigm shift in terms of
what human engineering
can do and they're always adding new
stuff on curiosity stream
they have documentaries on every topic
imaginable i can watch on every device i
own
and the best part is that when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman my audience gets 25
off that makes it 15 for the entire year
that is not a lot of money for the
amount of enjoyment
that i know you will get from
curiositystream and the link is right
underneath this video